so then just some fun about me my
keywords is Disney the cloud dogs
veggies I love Linux and somehow along
the way I got all involved in
distributed databases and that's what
we're gonna talk about today and that's
what I've been pretty much focusing on
for the last six years its distributed
databases also big data analytics
testing and running all right so what
are we gonna talk about today so what
problems are we actually trying to solve
so that's what we're gonna kind of talk
about in our overview then we're gonna
talk about what exactly is at Petri
Cassandra so just a quick show of hands
how many of you have heard of Cassandra
exactly but how much would you say you
know about it like you've heard of it
sure but do you know a lot about it like
thumbs up if you're like yeah I'm a
total expert extender okay cool then
this talk is for you so we're gonna
talking what it is and why you might
need it because with Cassandra and any
kind of distributed database not
necessarily something that everyone
needs for every project so we're going
to talk about what it is and when you
would need it and then you can kind of
decide in the future for your projects
whether you think you need it then we're
going to talk about very brief
introduction to Apache spark because
we're gonna be using spark a little bit
and we have very tight integrations
between Cassandra and spark with data
stacks so we're gonna talk about what it
is again why would you need it because
again not every project needs these
types of technologies then a very brief
introduction to what is sentiment
analysis then what does data stacks
enterprise analytics how does it help us
in this domain then we're gonna do an
overview of the demo and then we're
gonna set up and play with the demo on
your laptops with docker
so what problem are we really trying to
solve what movie should I see that's the
overarching what are we trying to do so
wouldn't it be great if I could ask 1
million people this question and
wouldn't it be great if I could automate
this process that I could actually do
this myself so well in short of it data
analytics does not have to be
complicated to analyze things it doesn't
have to be all these complicated floats
it can just be something as simple as
like I want to do some text analytics on
Twitter tweets so we're gonna utilize
the power of Big Data with Apache
Cassandra Apache spark spark machine
learning libraries Jupiter notebooks
Python
Twitter tweets in the Twitter API
actually in this case so I have a
notebook for you later that you can
review that you can actually I show you
how to set up a Twitter dev account so
that you can actually pull live Twitter
tweets using their API with Python um we
won't do that today because it takes a
little bit of time to actually apply for
that so I show you how to do that and
then in the future or even later today
if we have time you could start working
walking through that and we have a
notebook that'll help guide you through
that but in this case we're just gonna
use boring CSV files from Twitter tweets
that I pulled in advance and then just
learn to CSV files but so we're getting
part of the way there
and then we're gonna use a Python
package called pattern for the actual
sentiment analysis okay so what exactly
is Apache Cassandra so a fattie
Cassandra was first developed by
Facebook in 28-hour 2008 and then they
open sourced it and it became an
incubator Apache project and then two
years later it graduated it to a
top-level project now like I said I'm an
Apache commit on another project so I
know how complicated and house-like
stringent and serious that the Apache
foundation takes these types of projects
and allowing them to actually graduate
to top level so the fact that Cassandra
was able to do that in two years really
shows the community that they have
behind it so there's a lot of different
people from a lot of different companies
if you're not familiar with the Apache
model there's a lot of people from a lot
of different companies that all
contribute to the same project so data
sex has a majority of the contributors
to Cassandra but also places like Apple
and Facebook I think even some folks
that Amazon they also contribute to the
project so what is it exactly so now we
kind of know the history but it is a
distributed decentralized database so it
kind of you see in big bold they're
distributed this is a distributed
database so we're gonna run this
database on our laptops but that's not
the use case you don't use this database
when you have a small amount of data use
it when you have large amounts of data
so it's elastically scalable you can add
or remove nodes with no downtime there's
high performance it's very fast high
availability and fault tolerant there's
no single point of failure we're going
to talk about
that's kind of a that's a cool word that
sounds fun that's a nice phrase but why
is it actually no single point failure
we're gonna talk about in a minute and
it solves many of the problems faced
with traditional databases for certain
types of workloads again it doesn't fit
every use case so what does a sex
enterprise so that's the company I work
for so just I just like to just bring
this up just so that people know the
difference between the two basically
data sex enterprise is the production
ready version of Apache Cassandra so
there's more interesting stuff there but
I won't bore you with the details so
what does this all mean so let's talk
about the four big topics of what a
distributed database what it is
especially a database like Cassandra
so it's distributed the replication
elastically scalable and it has high
availability and they just put another
out here don't forget this is just a
brief intro so again it has to be
distributed to be able to handle big
data so every node in the cluster has
the same role
they really do there's no master worker
architecture in Cassandra so any client
can contact connect to any node and it's
able to do this for reads and writes
there's not there's not notes for reads
there's not notes for writes there's not
a master no there's not a client node
all the nodes are exactly the same but
this is not to say that all the nodes
contain all the data right that's that's
not very scalable so that's how we get
into the replication factor so to be
able to survive a node going down
because when we think about these
distributed clusters they're going to
have not just one node not just two
notes they may I think the largest
deployment of Cassandra that's at Apple
has like over 7,000 nodes so nodes will
go down they're going to fail so you
have to have your data replicas
replicated across nodes so that when one
node goes down your data is still
available so you can set this by the
user
the user can set the replication factor
so it can be anywhere from 1 up to 3 or
actually if you go all the way up to the
number of nodes that you have in your
cluster but that's not really
recommended so we always say it's just
up to 3 because the fact that the
likelihood of three of your nodes going
down that all contain the exact same
copy of the data that was randomly
distributed all going down the same time
it's very unlikely
so again the data is automatically
replicated you just write once and then
Cassandra takes care of the rest and it
replicates it across the the cluster so
again it's automatic and it's
peer-to-peer communication so you can
see here the nodes can talk to any node
can talk to any other node and that's
why you only need to talk to one node
and then it'll just get it out to the
other nodes elastically scalable so this
is an interesting thing about Cassandra
is that the more nodes you add your
performance will actually increase
linearly you can scale up and scale down
with no downtime you don't even need a
restart rejection I was really surprised
by so not only can you not only can you
add the nodes but you can also add the
nodes with no downtime at all with no
restart and both reads and writes both
scale so like I said I've worked on
quite a few different distributed
databases and I worked on one for a
while that I was actually working on
getting all the configuration so that we
can actually add notes so we didn't even
have the ability we couldn't even add
notes so I was helping work on that that
was great
we finally had the ability to add the
nodes in we could see it all across the
cluster you did a count you could see
you know okay now I have ten nodes but
we were running it and we're saying
we're not getting like we see with
Cassandra we're not getting an increase
in performance now not only we're not
getting linear increase but we're not
getting any well lo and behold the more
we work through it we had some
hard-coded values down in the code
because somewhere along the line
somebody thought there's no way that
anybody will ever have more than 50
notes so you're not gonna have that kind
of problem with Cassandra so high
availability so again this kind of
database is for a application that you
need that needs to be always on so the
lack of the masternodes
allows for high availability there is no
single point of failure and then
replication allowed notes to fail and
the data to still be available so
cassandra expects news to fail and
doesn't panic it was built with this in
mind it's ready for this to happen
also right out of the box with again
with high availability bility we have
multiple data center support right on
the box so you can have multiple data we
call them
that's a little bit of Cassandra
terminology so we have nodes which is
the individual servers and then from
there what I would probably call a
cluster they call it data center which
is a collection of locally connected
nodes and then out from there you have a
larger cluster that has multiple data
centers within it and the different data
centers could be in different regions so
say you could have it across US
different AWS availability zones even we
have multi cloud support as well so
here's just one small trade-off i wanted
to bring up to everyone because all the
kind of things I just said to you make
Cassandra and data stacks sound very
magical but nothing's magical right and
again I would developer advocate so I'm
not here to sell anybody anything or I
have no interested in any of that so I
want to bring up this interesting a part
of trade-off about data stacks and
cassandra and so that's around the fact
that it is an eventually consistent
database so that means that you may not
have your data the same across all nodes
and so this is all around the cap
theorem which this is just Ferb you
should do a little googling on this it's
kind of interesting basically you can't
have all of these things at the same
time you can't have availability
consisting of partitioning when your
nodes go down when there is a network
failure you can't have all these things
at the same time when everything's
running smoothly and running perfectly
you can so it's really impossible to how
all these things and so because of that
the standard chooses to have eventual
consistency so but you can prioritize
this in your queries over availability
so the consistency levels are
configurable so even though it isn't
eventually consistent database you can
tune it per query to actually be a
consistent database so just bring that
up to make sure everybody knows that
we're all being completely
straightforward and honest here okay so
let's get to the piece about why you
might need this why would this be
something your application needs so do
you have big data do you have a lot of
it do you need to be able to read and
write very fast do you need to be able
to
up and scale down very easily do you
need high availability do you need multi
data center support or more tape multi
cloud hybrid cloud all the different
ways that you can deploy something if
you need that kind of support then you
might want to consider using a database
like Cassandra or Cassandra alright so
let's get into our small introduction to
Apache spark so I don't know how many in
the room have actually used spark before
ok cool oh ok so we're gonna play just a
tiny bit with it today good ok nice so
Apache spark is a so I just took this
straight from their website because it's
a really great definition so somebody
obviously was like working really hard
like try to like actually get this
perfect explanation of what it is that
they do which is not easy to do so
Apache spark is a unified analytics
engine for large-scale data processing
so that's that key word there is
analytics engine so it's a hundred times
faster than Hadoop for analytics and
that's because it utilizes any member in
memory processing and it has amazing
parallelism so not only does spark have
the machine learning libraries that
we're going to utilize today it also has
the it has spark sequel spark streaming
again the spark machine learning
libraries graphics for like a graph
database type engine to do graph
analytics and spark our to do our work
so again this is super quick touch on
what spark is but why would you need
spark why would you want to use that
it's pretty obvious because of the
machine learning libraries why you'd
want to use spark if you're doing that
kind of analysis that's a crystal clear
but if you're not doing that you know it
may not be clear to why you might need
it so again if you have big data so this
is not for just small sets of data this
is not just for things that fit on your
laptop right if you need high
availability if you need analytics at
lightning speed and if you want to do
you need some simple ways to get some
insights into your data now again for
this crowd the PI data crowd come on
you're well aware of doing simple ways
to get inside
to your data you use Python to do these
things right but not everybody does and
so they can actually utilize spark to do
some of this and PI spark which is what
we're going to do later all right so if
you need any of these things you might
want to consider using Apache spark okay
what is sentiment analysis okay so this
again very light touch on what this is I
have a few friends who are professors in
data science and they barely be really
unhappy with me that I only have one
slide for cinnamon analysis but
nevertheless we don't need to know all
the math behind it we just kind of need
to know that cinnamon analysis is a
high-level is just a very simple way to
do natural language processing and text
analytics to determine things about a
word or a sentence so we're trying to
determine whether these sentences
positive negative or neutral or actually
in the the Python package that we're
gonna be using it doesn't really tell us
in neutral it just kind of says like I
don't know I don't really know what
you're trying to tell me so this is easy
for us to understand at a high level but
it's really difficult for machines to
learn how to do and just think it's even
difficult for just us now in the text
age to understand what people are trying
to say to us right think of those times
when somebody send you a text and it
just says okay it's just a period at the
end you're like okay well are they happy
with me are they sad with me what's the
problem so it's hard for us to interpret
these things so teaching a computer is
also extremely difficult but with some
of these techniques that we're gonna
work on today you'll see how we can do
this okay so this was awesome right we
have an understanding of these different
technologies now but now what okay so
these are just a few things different
ways that you can learn more about these
things if you have interest in that in
the future so you can learn more about
Cassandra at we have a free it's kind of
like Coursera it's called data sex
Academy it has tons of free classes all
you have to do is register about
Cassandra data statics spark
basically anything you want to know
about distributed databases you could go
there and learn more about it um also
another good place to learn about spark
it's just from their website there
again you can learn more about betta sex
on our website I tweet sometimes
interesting things sometimes not
interesting things but you can follow me
on Twitter and also we recently we
started a twitch so one of my co-workers
he's been twitching just things as he
goes along that tries to like get things
up and running kind of like what we're
doing today he would just put on twitch
so it's kind of it's actually more
entertaining than you think to watch
okay so let's start working on an
overview of the demo and so once we go
through that then we can kind of get you
all up and running and started with that
okay so we're gonna analyze Twitter with
Daz analytics and Jupiter so first off
I'm again like I said what we're gonna
do is I'm gonna walk through this just
the notebook so we know what we're doing
then we're gonna switch over to you all
doing it yourselves so we're gonna
install docker and of course I already
have it installed on my laptop but
that's kind of the path that we're gonna
take you're gonna install docker then
you're gonna install and run data stacks
enterprise and it also has Jupiter
included with it so you don't have to do
two installations just in the docker
container everything's there then from
there you're going to open up the
notebooks and we're gonna start walking
through it so from there we're gonna
create a database or we call it key
space we're gonna create tables we're
gonna insert our data into Cassandra
we're gonna also I should mention that
we're also gonna pull down these
notebooks from github so I'll show you
I'll point you all to where you can get
these notebooks we're gonna create a
spark data frame then we're gonna use
spark machine libraries to do some of
the sentiment analysis then we're gonna
pass that over to pandas with pattern
and that's gonna finally give us that
positive and negative we're gonna take
an average of these scores and then
we're gonna decide hey should I see this
movie okay so now it's hands-on time let
me switch over to my notebook so I'll
come back to these instructions here
once I kind of walk through the notebook
okay so here's my Jupiter instance I'll
make this larger so here we are in the
the notebooks directory so it's just
automatically once you'll see once you
start it you'll see it just a
automatically take you to the notebooks
directory we also have a folder with our
data and that's where you can see like
this is where I brought them into CSV
files let's go back here we have some
images just so that we can show some
nice images in the notebook then I have
some more information about installation
that was kind of what I was talking
about let me go back here sorry about
that
that's where you can get more
information to actually set up that
Twitter API so you can actually start
pulling live Twitter data on any search
term that you have and I can watch if
anybody's interested in actually getting
that set up later when we're just
walking on it working on this together
just raise your hand and I can come over
and help you if it's it's a little bit
confusing but it's a once you do it the
first time you kind of know how to do it
forever and then we have a notebook here
that actually has this is the other
notebook that actually will use those
Twitter API to pull live data so let's
start walking through this one so this
is the one that we're gonna focus on the
most so this is the demo using data sex
Enterprise Cassandra SPARC Python
Jupiter notebooks Twitter tweets Python
pattern and sentiment analysis so it's a
lot of things all wrapped up into one
because that's kind of one of my
favorite things is I love seeing how you
can integrate different technologies all
together to do something in this case
kind of fun and not so difficult not
difficult to understand it all so some
of the things that we'll need to set up
and so you're gonna work through
actually another notebook that'll help
you with that setup process and I'll
show you that at the end here so we're
gonna work through the installation of
DSC and Jupiter notebook for the set of
instructions and like I said on your
free time try to get the Twitter dev API
up and running and you can use it
utilize the other notebook for this so
this example we use the CSV files so
just here and we're gonna we're just
gonna run this so here this is just
something I have to actually a bug that
I've actually passed back to one of our
developers he's actually already fixed
it in one of our later releases but
basically you don't have to tell Python
or PI spark utilize the PI spark that's
within DSC which is data sacks
enterprise because like I said
they're co-located so utilize this don't
try to utilize any other one that you
may have and then just append that and
so then we're gonna import some of our
Python packages here and okay see
everyone's gonna get this error just
ignore it and just run it again it's
fine so let's talk some of the things
that we're actually gonna use we're
gonna use pandas we're gonna use the
Cassandra driver the Python driver to
connect from with Python to Cassandra to
the database we're gonna use PI spark
and we're going to utilize this PI spark
that's within data stacks we're gonna
use regular expressions the OS library
we're going to use some display again
markdown right so we can have these nice
nice markdown here and then just some of
the things from the PI spark tokenize
stop word remover and we'll talk about
that as we go along so then just here I
just have a nice helper functions it's
kind of like make the spark data frames
display a little bit nicer all right so
we're gonna create the tables and then
we're gonna load the tweets so here
we're just creating a cluster session
basically it's saying connect to my
database and then give me a session back
and then we're gonna create so again in
Cassandra and data stacks instead of a
database we call it a key space and
that's where all our tables will live
under that so we're gonna create one
we're gonna call it demo one and then as
you can see here this is what I was
talking about before with this
replication factor so now in this case
because we're not working on distributed
systems per se right we're working on a
single node we don't need to set the
replication factor to anything other
greater than one those we're only gonna
have one node and then we just right
here so we don't have to keep
referencing it okay so now this is where
stuff gets to get start to get a little
bit fun so set the movie title level so
you can change this to search for
different movies so even with the CSV
file for format that we're using here
I've loaded multiple of those so you're
able to look between Mamamia to first
man a star is born and mission
actually have a star is born but I'm
gonna change it to Mission Impossible
okay so let's run that there so that
just sets the movie title total we don't
have to keep we can just use that
throughout so then we just have a list
here of positive and negative because
something interesting I learned and I
think I talked about this a little bit
later so Twitter actually when you're
pulling from the API it actually will do
a first pass at trying to do sentiment
analysis so if you sir have a search
term that you give it with a smiley face
it will try to pull all your positive
positive tweets it has about that search
term and if you have a sad face
literally a sad face it pulls all the
negative tweets so it actually already
tries to do a first pass at that so
that's we're kind of utilizing that and
building on that to be able to pull
positive and negative tweets but what
you'll see here and I think you'll see
as well it does a really good job of
pulling positive tweets it's very good
at finding that sentiment but it's
really rocky and I would almost say it
doesn't work for the negative I don't
know if it's just something that used to
work and now it doesn't work and I mean
this is a free service so maybe they're
not that worried about it but it's just
interesting and it's something for us to
play with us we play with these
notebooks so we're gonna create two
tables and Cassandra for the movie
titles one for negative tweets and one
for positive tweets so I'm Twitter
actually returns a lot of information
and if you get um if you get that API
set up for yourself you'll see that it
pulls way more information than you
probably ever thought it would it's kind
of nerve-wracking because it actually
pulls the Twitter ID so that's unique to
each person who tweets and then it
sweets it gives you all this other
information back about them geolocation
followers friends everything but in this
case we don't really need all that extra
information even though for you in the
future doing analysis that may be
information that you actually do want
but for us all we really need is a
unique ID to partition our data by and
the tweet so we create a table here so
if it doesn't exist create a table
with columns of a big inch for the
twitter ID and a text column for the
tweet and then our primary key is around
that twitter ID so cassandra needs a
primary key when it partitions the data
and that key must be unique which we're
lucky with the twitter ID that it is
unique all right then let's load the
Twitter tweets poll from Twitter and
store in a CSV file these are pulled
from Twitter so I do this in advance so
basically we're gonna let's make sure I
run this I didn't create my table yet
alright so basically it just opens up
the file and then it goes per line and
then what it's gonna do is just insert
it so you see this insert statement here
and that'll insert that into Cassandra
alright it's pretty fast which is nice
so we loaded the negative ones so now we
can load the positive one so now we can
do a select star on each table and
verify that the tweets have actually
been inserted so let's
okay cool
so we see they both were and start both
the live and the negative tweets were
loaded okay great okay so now where I
start doing some analytics we're going
to we're going to use Apache spark
I'm doing here in this table this is
gonna take actually a little bit to run
I'm connecting into I'm connecting
between Cassandra and spark so I'm
saying okay I want a spark session
connect to my master that lives in data
stacks and then from there I'm going to
make a connection with the table so I
want to pull that information all that
information from that Cassandra table
and I want to make that into a spark
data frame so we now have two spark data
frames one with table with positive
tweets and we'll the table with negative
tweets and so just to make sure that
this that this actually happened right
again with spark it has lazy execution
so it doesn't actually do anything until
you give it an action so in this so this
isn't enough of an action to create a
data frame case we need that later okay
so doing this count and doing like a
selects select count star on that will
actually give us that count so in this
case again like I said we don't have big
data this is small data so we have 50
columns or 50 rows in our positive and
75 and our negative so now we're
tokenize this up we need to break up
these sentences into individual words
because pattern the Python library that
we're gonna use later it can't just take
a whole sentence it needs you to chop it
up so that's pretty simple and we're
utilizing the power of spark now again
you all know that we could have also
done this probably with the probably
numerous Python packages that could have
entered the libraries that could have
done this but we're utilizing spark
because again even though this is just
on one node and we do only have you know
50 rows but if we had big data if we had
you know a hundred nodes with terabytes
of data we could use this exact same
command with spark and honestly it would
take similar amount of time that it's
taking on the small bit of data for much
larger bits of data so just keep that in
mind a lot of this is not something that
you necessarily would use on your laptop
but if you have a large scale
application this might be something you
want to use okay so we've broken it up
into any
dual words not I mean we printed it here
in a nice data frame nice output but
it's nothing quite interesting yet we
are getting a number of tokens so a
number of words per sentence but
nothing's that interesting so now it's
when we're starting to get to something
a little bit interesting so now we're
gonna remove all the stop words so
basically what we're saying I don't stop
words are anything like of a the all
those other little words we're gonna
just strip those out because we're gonna
say okay I don't want to get I don't
want pattern when it's doing it cinnamon
analysis to get confused so let's do
that and so what's nice about this so as
you can see this is just three lines of
code that's doing that for us that's
creating this new data frame with the
stop with an addition of a column of the
words that are tokenized but removing
the stop words and so we're gonna print
those out here so we have the original
tweet then we have the tokenized words
just the words then we have these stop
words actually removed and then we have
a count of the original number of words
that were in the sentence and now that
we've removed the stop words how many
words are actually there so you can
already start to see it it's a little
bit interesting I mean we again we have
a small data set here but could already
see that they remove we've gotten rid of
quite a few words here so in this case
there was literally 20 words in the
sentence and now there's only 12 okay so
now I think this is what this crowd came
for which is actually using the Python
package pattern with for sentiment
analysis so in this case what we're
gonna do is we're going to convert the
spark data frame to a panda's data frame
now I just want to let everybody know
this works as is because we're working
on a small data set on our laptop now if
I was working like I said in those
large-scale applications you can't just
take a spark data frame and then just
put it into a panel frame unless the
server that pandas is running on is very
large has a lot of memory so it's not
something that you just do you do want
to take a subset because otherwise it's
not it's gonna overload your memory
crash your computer all right so from
here we're gonna do a loop and get the
sentiment score so any
think that is positive is positive
anything negative or zero is negative so
there's a positive function here you see
if I can highlight it for you this here
will return true if the tweet is
actually positive and then there's an
assessment function that will show you
which words were used to judge and score
each of the words so this is a little
confusing right here but if we just run
it we can easily see okay it prints out
here in a nice data frame okay so here's
the original tweet and here's our
sentiment score so again these are
negative tweets the fact that we're
getting negative scores is good right
that's what we are expecting so we see
our score here then we see whether it
was positive or negative a true or false
and in this case false it's not positive
right which again what we're expecting
and then here's the assessment this is
where it it's actually fun to start
playing with these things and when you
when you walk through this yourself you
can try the different movies and see if
you're getting different results so in
this case we're seeing something
interesting right so we search for the
movie mission impossible so when it
takes an assessment of what are the
words that it used to actually determine
the sentiment of the statement or seeing
something not great we're seeing the
word impossible it's utilizing that word
and saying oh impossible that's a
negative word that's not a positive word
so I'm gonna score this really low I'm
gonna say this was a very negative
sentiment and just the and also it's
very negative right 0.6 that's really
close to like that's extremely negative
so look you can see sad is 0.5 so
impossible is even more of a negative
word than sad okay so we have all those
scores there so now let's do some for
positive here okay so we're doing the
same thing we have our original tweet
let's see if we can find one okay let's
see if we can find one that's really
really positive
okay well I can't seem to find one right
now but we can when we're walking
through it individually you can try that
out
but anyways here's our original tweet
here's our sentiment score so we're
getting whether it's if it's positive or
negative so in this case we're mostly
seeing true we're seeing a few false
here again interesting because then we
can come over here to the assessment
let me see okay well what did it what
word did it use to create this score
again we're kind of seeing the word
impossible show up here hmm or also say
nice great good quick fair worth best
right positive words okay so all right
so should I see this movie so how in
this case how I'm determining whether
you should see the movie or not is I'm
gonna take an average of all the
sentiment scores and then if the
positive score is higher than the
negative score I'm gonna say okay well
it seems to have a really good positive
sentiment around it so people should go
and if they're equal I'm saying okay
it's split you know take a chance do
what you want to do and if the negative
score is greater than the positive score
I say people don't like this movie don't
go see it so let's see what we get here
okay so our our positive ratings average
score was 0.2 and our negative ratings
score was negative 0.4 so I'm saying
people don't like this movie don't go
see it but now when I did this
originally when I did this talk Mission
Impossible just come out I'm super
popular right didn't everybody everybody
liked it I think it had like a crazy
high Rotten Tomatoes score so something
something has this is not what we were
expecting right we're expecting to say
people should go see this movie so if
this answer was not what you were
expecting really either way you should
go back and take a look at it right data
science is an iterative process right so
let's let's try this again
but let's remove some extra stop words
so let's remove right because we saw
that impossible was really weighing down
our scores so let's remove that let's
remove the movie title because
movie title in itself is almost like a
stop-work right it's not adding anything
to the sentiment at all it's just the
title it's just trying to describe what
it is I'm trying to describe so let's
remove the movie title let's remove any
like extra happy faces or sad faces then
let's remove the words mission again
because I had already done this in
advance so I knew some of the words that
might be affecting it so in this case
for some of those movie titles we had
I'm gonna remove Mission Impossible Star
for a star is born and first so we're
gonna we're gonna create a list of stop
words and then we're gonna go through
that same process of again of removing
stop word to a spark but in this time
instead of just taking kind of the
default stop words that spark has we're
gonna take this list and pass it in so
in this case which I was kind of
disappointed in I thought that what it
would do is take this list and the list
of kind of normal stop words and kind of
concatenate them together and put it
together it doesn't it only if you can
use either use the defaults or you can
use your own list so we are going to get
in our next set we're gonna get things
like of an A and are still going to be
there but I think it's okay so again
we're gonna run through this process
again okay
and we're gonna go through here and so
now so we've removed all these our new
set of stop words and then we're going
to use them again we're going to convert
it to pandas use the pattern Python
package to get the cinnamon and to get
the average so now we're starting to see
so this is our set of negative tweets so
now we're starting to see I think what
we were expecting right here's a
negative sentiment score of 0.7 and the
assessment is why is it 0.7 because I
had the word bad no but actually
unfortunate if we look back at the
original tweet again it's kind of
interesting actually what the person is
saying is I want to see mission
impossible so bad so that's not that's
not really a negative sentiment and it's
not really a negative movie review per
se but nevertheless we see why the
Python package rated it this way and it
makes sense and we're not seeing those
very negative scores based on the words
impossible and then some of these here
we see we're getting 0.0 it's because it
just doesn't python just doesn't
understand it doesn't know how to rate
this okay so let's go to our positive
once again we're going to convert to
pandas and use pattern to get the
sentiment and then take the average okay
so this now we did better before before
we move the mission impossible' stop
words but now we're starting to see
again we're seeing more positive because
it's not being weighed down by that
impossible keyword she's saying things
like free awesome amazing totally loved
yeah totally loved the action in Mission
Impossible 6 it's a pretty good movie
review ok so let's see if there was a
difference so we're gonna do that same
thing that we did before take the
averages all right so our original
positive rating score was 0.2 and now
our positive rating score is 0.3 okay
which is again it's a little bit higher
but it's kind of making sense what we
saw before our original negative rating
is 0.4 and our now our new negative
rating is 0.15 now
things are starting to the line out now
things are making sense so if we take
the average of that and we compare them
we now see people like this movie which
makes sense people like this movie all
right so that's what the notebook is so
now now we can all play with this
ourselves our laptop so I hope
everybody's ready so let's go here so
what everybody wants to do is go here to
github and then it's slash my name
Amanda Moran slash PI data and what you
can do is you can either just download
it you can download zip and unzip it or
you can do a git clone from here so I'll
give everybody a second to do that if
you have it already and then come in
here to your notebooks and so what um
actually something I just learned the
other day is with Jupiter so I have a
notebook that I want you to look at to
give you instructions right but you
don't necessarily have Jupiter installed
yet so how do I let you see that Jupiter
notebook well actually there's a very
nice command in Jupiter that can convert
it into an HTML file so once you do the
ER get clone what I want you to do is
actually just go and find that file so
let's go find that later but so this one
here getting started dot HTML just
double click on that and it'll pop it up
you can also just look at it from github
either way oh but it doesn't show it
here nicely okay
backtrack that yeah definitely double
click and open it up
okay
so once you have that onto your laptop
then we're gonna install docker so I'll
give everyone a second to get all level
set on that I'll make this larger
so if you don't already have docker
installed on your laptop we'll need to
do that so so you'll have to download it
from here you want to use the Community
Edition because the I think there's like
an advanced Enterprise Edition but you
have to pay for that so you can just get
the Enterprise Edition and I have a link
in that notebook and I think you do have
to create a login to download and then
you'll download docker and that may take
about five minutes or so and then
there's a few configurations that you
need to change in docker once you get
that installed
does anybody already have it installed
okay okay cool how long did it take
about ten minutes yeah yeah okay five
minutes yeah yeah and then we have to
download the DSC I mentioned that's
gonna take a little bit of time too
and feel free I'm kind of walking
through this as we go along but feel
free to just jump ahead and keep going
or if you have questions just raise your
hand and
but did everybody get to github okay
so this all takes a little bit more time
with like downloading and things like
that
but way less time in installation
because originally I had us actually
installing data stacks and spark from
our tire file and this is much easier
so anybody that already has docker
installed you have to allow for five
gigs of memory container so you just go
into now I have a Mac so if anybody's on
Windows I'm sure it's similar I don't
actually know though but you go to
docker preferences and advanced and then
there's a memory setting you just slide
that over to five but if you're not
there yet don't worry we have plenty of
time
you
so then once you have that configured or
even if you don't have the memory
configured yet but the next step is that
you're gonna do actually and I'll show
this from my terminal you're gonna open
up a terminal and you're gonna go to
where you actually downloaded those
downloaded the notebooks so in my case
it's my path and then PI data and so
from there I'm gonna do a docker compose
I think it's up d yeah I always get
those swapped and then that's actually
gonna pull the image from docker and
that takes about five minutes so then
you just hit in here so I'll just go
ahead and do that
oops live demo
okay yeah so from there you'll do a
docker compose up - D and so you can see
here I've already pulled those images so
we're gonna have a DSC image and a
Jupiter image and so mine are already up
to date so it didn't do anything but
then once you get to this stage then
it's about five minutes
but after we get through that step then
we're able to pull up Jupiter once those
get started so this is kind of the hard
tedious part right now but then then
we'll be good to go
anybody having issues downloading docker
is everybody okay
how many people have used docker in the
room okay
and so that docker compose up not only
will it download the images but also
start them as well so that's starting
data stacks Enterprise for this will
basically Cassandra it's starting spark
and a starting Jupiter
has anybody got to the docker compose
the pulling the images yet is it coming
down okay
okay good okay okay good
um from the terminal I'll show you again
so then you navigate into where you did
your get clone so this is mine here say
this is kind of small sorry hey see that
now so then there's that docker compose
file so if anybody's interested we can
actually take a look at it but that's
where you'll run that docker compose -
do yeah so actually it's utilizing this
docker compose dot yamo file to actually
know what it needs to do so it's saying
okay I'm gonna get the data sack server
image I'm gonna start it with a dash K
so basically that says I want to start
in an analytics mode then it just Maps
some ports it accepts the license and
then here's the Jupiter image it's
actually this is an image that my boss
created which is nice
and again mapping those ports Jupiter
ports and then it says okay I want to
use the notebooks from this location and
and dock those and so that we are able
to use them in the docker container
so once it pulls down the image so I'm
just kind of just repeating this as I go
along so don't know one feel rushed we
still have plenty of time to go through
this but kind of the trickiest part I
think here is the fact that you need to
use docker to open up the logs so that
you can actually get the token for a
Jupiter so that you can actually open it
so you'll see this once you get get down
to this point but once it start
downloaded and started so you need to
actually to get that login token you
need to go right where you were at the
same place where you did the poll from
docker logs and then the actual the name
of the container the docker container
which in this case is PI data underscore
Jupiter underscore one and so from there
you're gonna see for some of the last
things that'll print out of that log
it's just gonna cat it to the the
terminal there you're gonna see this
HTTP and then this long token string so
just highlight all of that and then here
I could I could I could show you
so in this case we're seeing mine
actually has a lot of activity because
it actually been using it but I think if
we scroll back up here to the top yeah
you should see copy and paste this URL
into your browser when you connect for
the first time and so you see it has
you're gonna use localhost so you want
127 dot 0 dot 0 dot 1 so just highlight
this whole thing or whatever yours is
right copy it then go back to your
browser paste it in and then get rid of
all this extra that it provides now go
through this again in a minute like that
and then you should be able to get into
Jupiter
but yeah that's one of the that's the
most tricky part ya know it should that
docker compose up should have started it
should have let me know if it did not
you can also do I'll show you from here
docker PS and that should show any
containers that you have running
so hopefully you should see two two
containers
if you do docker logs and then the PI
data underscore Jupiter underscore one
yeah let me know if it it works
hopefully is it there okay good so the
instructions that you write actually
translate into what what people are
saying so that's very good I'm happy
with that
so can I see like a show of hands who
has darker installed okay good great
good progress nice and so everyone is
working on just getting that image
downloaded now cool okay great
you
you should be there's there's docker for
Windows
there's no Community Edition for Windows
oh yeah if there's not the Community
Edition that I'm thinking I'm surprised
though yeah yeah well I mean I guess it
kind of makes sense that unlikely that
someone was using docker on their home
PC but nevertheless is able yeah okay
and then sadly so I could say okay well
we could go a different route and you
could do you could just install DSC but
you can't install it's Linux based so so
that's when you share with your neighbor
we're going it together
so one of the interesting things is if
you forget to to modify the memory for
the containers which I just did the
other day I completely had forgotten
about it I had reduced the memory of my
daughter containers because I didn't
want to take any of a bunch of memory so
everything will work perfectly until you
get to the spark jobs and spark because
again it's an in-memory analytics engine
it needs a lot of memory so it just will
just spin there forever without enough
memories
so I think this is pretty good for a
Sunday morning right
interacting with docker Jupiter Python
spark that's a lot of a lot of different
technologies all for one early morning
hasn't even been able to get the Jew or
Jupiter login yet
oh sorry
and so then one see if you do have
Jupiter pulled up then that's when you
can navigate to the notebook and you can
start kind of playing with it yourself
so here if you're in your can make this
larger this home directory you can see
when Rotten Tomatoes isn't enough and
that's the and I called it CSV because
it's utilizing with CSV files so yeah I
think definitely the most fun part would
just be kind of walking through each one
of these cells yourself and really
making sure you understand what's going
on in each one and also tweaking the
movie title so you can see if you're
getting I think the most interesting
part is seeing those assessment scores
and those final scores on all these
different so we saw something very
interesting with Mission Impossible
because it was utilizing that impossible
word and that was kind of skewing our
results but then we'll see if we were
kind of seeing that with any of the
other ones
or the images or is it coming through
okay it's downloading
I was remind everyone that Jupiter URL
is located inside that docker log file
so if you go to if you go here to your
terminal and you docker logs and then
the name of the container so in this
case is PI data underscore Jupiter
underscore one and that it'll just it'll
just print out to your screen yeah yeah
it's more of a log command I guess then
a log file I mean it's a file inside the
docker container but we're using a
command to get to it as opposed to
looking at looking at it with VI or
something like that
oh yeah yeah oh okay it wasn't just
right at the end there had been activity
okay that makes sense
yeah that's a good idea so the command
would look like this so you do docker
logs and then the name of the container
then a pipe and then grab and then for
token yeah okay well I have a token a
few places here but it should pop up a
little bit better
I don't we could do this
still no oh yeah that there it is yeah
yeah that there
so how many people have the image
downloaded other people just still
waiting it's just slow
I think we'll do maybe another like
seven minutes or so of people trying to
get this downloaded and working through
it on your own and then after that we
can kind of open it up for like come
some questions yeah so we don't have to
feel so quiet working away and what's
nice about this which is different than
some of the other events I do where we
provide clusters to folks is that those
go away this you can have forever and
you can continue to play with it
whenever you have free time
you
you
show you this other notebook that
actually pulls the tweets live and I can
show you I can walk you through kind of
just the difference here so here it's
basically the same type of setup except
I'll show you the differences so again
we have our search terms right which
again like I said before with the happy
face in the smiley face or the sad face
they actually pull from Twitter so we
need those search terms and then in this
case we also have a way to clean up the
tweets because we have to be able to
strip out any emojis or flags or I
stripped out any URLs or the RT for
retweet and so this is where you need to
actually get that Twitter API dev
account set up because what it'll do is
it'll give you these consumer keys to
keys and to secret tokens and so in this
case I've you can just copy and paste
them here but I've decided that I've
kind of hidden them in my environment
variables so that I don't have to change
them so no one can see them so you just
set this here and then you're able to
make that authentication with these
three lines here and so then that
actually authenticates you and so then
Twitter knows that it's you and the
reason actually I decided that we
wouldn't sign up for this together today
is because you actually have to submit
an application it's pretty quick it's
about five minutes but nevertheless you
do have to say okay I'm only using this
for personal use I'm not using this in
an enterprise account I'm not trying to
you know I'm not trying to use this data
to do anything bad with it that kind of
thing so you do have to fill out like
this little application ticket these
these tokens and actually they've made
it more strict over time it used to be
when I did this like last year I just
like basically this click click and I
signed up and they gave me these tokens
and now they're making it a little bit
more rigorous which makes sense it's a
very nice service that they're providing
and so then what we were able to do is
we're actually able to pull so we pull
from Twitter here in this line of code
and so again like we're like I said
before we're doing it twice because
we're doing it for positive and negative
so we add our
search term now this is using the Python
package called twee P and tweet V's
actually what's the Python wrapper
around these API calls and so once we
did we enter in the search term we say
we want the language we went only
English in this case and then I said
count as a hundred so again when you're
not paying for these access to this
Twitter API you're just using the
regular UNAM non-enterprise version it
only allows you to pull so many at one
time so in this case it only it's only
I'm giving a max of a hundred at one
time and so even if you it gives you 15
pulls per hour
I've found that even if I if I keep like
you know like I put it in a loop and I'm
trying to get you know 15 calls of a
hundred it doesn't actually work that
way they seem to kind of throttle you in
the backend as well but nevertheless I
mean you're able to pull some live data
which is very interesting and so from
there in this case I just I cleaned it
up I passed it to that cleanup function
and then I'm able to then insert it into
the database and that's what I do and
then I'm able to just take a select star
and like look at it so in this case in
this notebook I screw up here so here I
put a movie title this one it's not
limited to how we did with the CSV you
can actually search for anything I mean
in this case you don't even really have
to look for a movie title right you can
just any kind of thing that you're
interested in something you know new and
exciting that's happening you want to
search for and get the sentiment about
it in this case I just use movie titles
just to make it you know very tangible
but you could really search for anything
but again they are it does live come
from Twitter so if you're ever demoing
this be careful because those are live
tweets and they may have some language
that you may not want everyone to see
so those CSV files that I created I
actually did pull from Twitter but then
I went through and I read each and every
line to make sure that there wasn't
anything inappropriate so this then from
there once we actually pull it from
Twitter everything is exactly the same
as like what we've done before it's just
we're getting that live data that in
this case we didn't sentiments the same
everything is exactly the same so yeah I
definitely if you haven't played with it
before I definitely
yes it's it's very interesting it's a
very interesting data set that you can
utilize you don't get a whole lot of
data it's not big data I like I said
because they kind of throttle you there
but it's something you unique that that
you can have a new tool in your toolbox
so has ever been able to get to the
Jupiter pulled up cool okay great
good so we have about ten minutes left
so do we have any questions yeah in that
soup that docker compose file so that is
that docker compose dot yeah Mille
that's the configuration file and then
that Jupiter container so that was made
from a an image so you can see here so
the image with all the Python packages
and and all that was already created
here and then pushed up into docker and
so that's how we're able to pull it down
already has everything there that's
right
yeah and also um but the exo let me show
you here so we have Jupiter here but
we're making the connection into data
stacks and cassandra in this call here
yes so because it makes it a little bit
easier because it's localhost right so I
just did okay connected this Cassandra
there but yeah that's all you have to do
that's where the connection is
right right yeah
any other questions anybody has I know
everyone's probably yeah yep you got it
exactly yep exactly you said that better
than I did thank you I'm gonna steal bet
yeah that's exactly right it's just that
so actually when I started a date of
Stax so I worked a lot with spark and
Hadoop in the past and I was asking my
boss I said okay can I get a spark
cluster and he's like we don't have what
do you mean a spark cluster I'm like I
know you said I could use spark you said
I could use analytics I want a spark
cluster and I'm gonna connect the two
he said no no it's co-located it's like
Oh Cassandra is the back end as opposed
to HDFS yeah
yeah that's kind of where I go back to
in this case with a small amount of data
on your laptop it you don't really need
I mean you could use all kinds of
different things you can just use
straight CSV file to use it just a
regular flat file but this is just kind
of showing you know you can imagine if
you had an application at scale this
scales out to that this is just a sample
on your laptop
that's the I'll ask you all a question
so I found pattern and I thought that
worked pretty well for the sentiment
analysis but is anybody aware of any
other Python packages that would have
done done the job if you don't know
that's ok - I'm just wondering it seemed
it seemed to do exactly what I needed -
it gave that nice assessment of each
word but I'm sure there's something
there's a lot of Python data science
packages out there ok ok yeah I should
look into that one
you
normally get a lot of questions because
at the end of the in the past when I've
given this presentation at the end I
don't have us go back through where we
removed the new set of stop words that
include the movie so then people get
because I didn't have time to add that
piece in and I thought it what's pretty
interesting how much it was like giving
some skew to the data right and that but
people normally have a lot of questions
about how you could go back through and
how you could how you could fix that but
with spark it's really easy you just add
that list of stop words and it solves
that for you
so I just ran through first man and the
positive readings score we got four that
was zero point three and the negative
reading score was negative zero point
one so that was the first pass so now
I'm gonna run through it again removing
that word first let's see if it has any
effect so let's see
and my negative number of tweets for
first men it's actually really small I
think it's the line like seven tweets I
couldn't really find there wasn't people
weren't saying negative things about it
okay this scores are pretty similar
yeah yeah so that wait so when you had
that you'd want to make sure that
wherever you're running pandas from so
be it your laptop or you want to make
sure that you have the memory that
you'll need to move that data set over
so it just really depend on the size of
your data set exactly exactly yeah
or you'd make sure yeah yeah have more
memory yeah but you could use some you
know you wouldn't use your laptop for
that you would you know you suck a
server that you had at work or something
like that
yeah yeah that one is in that has
actually where you can use your Twitter
depth that one is in more notebooks yeah
so if we don't have any more questions
I'm just gonna post up here that again
there's the more information more links
so you can go learn more about these
things if you have any interest and then
just let you guys know data stacks is
hiring so we have a lot of job listings
on our website so feel free to we don't
have like a booth here today or anything
like that's just me but yeah feel free
to reach out to me on LinkedIn feel free
to apply online and then ping me and let
me know and I can get our recruiters
going but yeah so we don't necessarily
we work on the database so we don't do a
lot of data science but yeah this is
something you're interested you're
interested in distributed systems also
we are a remote company so you can if
you live here in LA you can stay here in
LA our headquarters is actually in Santa
Clara but most people work remotely so
so I'll wrap that up give you guys just
a few a little bit of time back and so
thank you very much I hope this was
useful
[Applause]